wie viel verdienst du beziehungsweise
wie viel hat man dort pro stunde
ungefähr verdient mindestlohn oder ein
bisschen mehr hey leute was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
ich hoffe jetzt auch gut das ist nämlich
die karrubis heute dabei ich musste erst
mal sagen sehr professionell ich hatte
eigentlich vor dass heute somit
anstecken die kosten machen auf richtig
professionell leider waren die irgendwie
kaputt ging nicht richtig an
deswegen machen wir das mit meinem
iphone also das ist heute das und zwar
freue ich mich sehr dass du heute hier
bist sie hat mir bei einzahlungen
geschrieben die video idee von dem
heutigen video kommt eigentlich komplett
von dir also ich fand sie gut und habe
gesagt ey wenn der bock hast kommt
nochmal vorbei und das hat sie gemacht
sie ist heute über fünf stunden aus
niedersachsen her gefahren hier nach
köln einfach nur mit mir dieses video zu
drehen und machen heute so ein interview
weil sie gerne meine videos schaut und
auch mal so das eine oder andere
mcdonald's video geguckt hat und gesagt
hat du hast immer so viele fragen
beantwortet ihr die allemal weil sie von
2018 bis 2019 bei mcdonald's selber
gearbeitet hat und deswegen wie heute
ich komme aus
ok also ich habe bei instagram gestern
gesagt bei dem slogan heisst alex wie
konnte er gern mal vorbei schauen dass
die leute mir fragen stellen können
wegen der oder an dich und das haben
sehr viele gemacht wir haben ultra viele
fragen zusammen manche habe ich 20 30
mal gelesen also 20 30 leute hatten die
gleiche frage und ich habe die 20 besten
ausgewählt die stelle ich dir jetzt
gleich und ich würde sagen wir fangen
direkt mal an
also wenn du irgendwas nicht beantworten
willst dann sagt das kann ich verstehen
weil du meinst ja dass du auf bestimmte
dinge nicht eingehen kann wenn man da ja
so ein vertrag unterschreibt dass man
keine betriebsgeheimnisse auffordern
kann aber das ist ja überall sozusagen
gar nicht schlimm und ja also einfach
sagen okay gibt es noch irgendwas zu
sagen ich glaube nicht es kann ein sehr
langes video werden also wirklich bei
den ganzen fragen deswegen vielleicht
sollten wir das in zwei teile und ich
habe ja schon gesagt den zweiten part
machen wir dann eventuell im auto
das ok also ich freue mich auf die
ganzen antworten wirklich weil mich
viele davon extrem interessieren wir
fangen ich fange einfach mal so kreuz
und quer an mit der ersten frage und
zwar das wird sehr sehr oft gefragt weil
das er auf you tube dieser trend selben
trend ist hast du mal live ein break von
einem youtuber miterlebt also weißt du
dass das sich halt irgendwie verarschen
wollte an
an diesem schalter also wie ich schon
gesagt habe ich wohl ab ende der welt
allein also meine antwort ist ganz
einfach neue also wir hatten doch
nirgendwo irgendein youtuber der sitze
dachte soll jetzt endlich mal irgendwie
mitarbeitern ja gut also ich glaube dass
es hier so in köln oder im ruhrgebiet
viel krasser ich kann ja auch den ein
oder anderen er sowas öfter macht und
der meinte der stimmigen wurden fand
weil er immer direkt erkannt wird und
weggeschickt wird also hätte mich jetzt
auch gewundert wenn das bei dir schon
vorgekommen ist aber es gibt ja immer so
war dorf bambus sage ich mal die auch
sein so youtube machen wollen und dass
man halt auch machen ich glaube dass in
köln so was einfach übliches war ich
würde auch generell viel gefilmt und bei
uns ist einfach nichts also gut
zweite frage machen wir direkt am anfang
ich weiß eigentlich schon die antwort
aber das haben sehr viele gefragt auch
weil ich das schon mal thematisiert habe
warum ist immer eure eismaschinen kaputt
beziehungsweise meistens abends gibt es
ja kein eis mehr wird immer gesagt hier
ist kaputt vorliegt also meistens liegt
da liegt es daran dass die eismaschine
eben geputzt werden muss das wissen
viele nicht aber bei uns ist das zum
beispiel so dass oft entweder zum
beispiel auch das als das nachgefüllt
dann muss also die focus also die saucen
die halt nicht mehr vorhanden sind
wieder schon kunde auch sonst kam der
neu ist die müssen auch nachgefüllt
werden und in der zeit oder plötzlich so
ein dreister 10.000 bestellungen sind
kann dann halt eben kein eis ausgegeben
werden weil das erstmal nachgefüllt
werden auswählen und alles ist das
meistens oder nachts bei uns ist das so
dass halt um 23 uhr morgens dann hast du
die ganzen leute plötzlich auf die
spontane idee kommen sich nun milchshake
zu bestellen
die ganzen kids die kommen nicht nur
klar das ist das war auch so eine frage
also stelle ich hier gleich noch dass
wir da dann kein eis mehr ausgeben
können weil dann ab 23 uhr morgens hat
die maschine dann halt ausgestellt wird
weil sie sich selber
und wie er sagt jedoch nicht so jung
also liegt halt daran bei wenigerath
räubern müssten weil die meisten ja die
ist kaputt also fast ihr auch ehrlich
sagen ich warum die sagen die ist kaputt
weil eigentlich also in unseren betrieb
zu sagen wir immer das weil ich habe bis
jetzt auch nie gehört so die wird
gesäubert oder der magnolia die ist
kaputt und dann denkt man sich halt
immer sowieso ist immer eure scheiße
maschine kaputt das kann doch nicht sein
aber gut also ich hab es gehört zwar die
antwort darauf sehr interessant das habe
ich mich auch schon oft gefragt weil bei
mir geht das klappt das irgendwie nie du
darfst ja kein trinkgeld annehmen dort
ist es richtig ja dafür nicht also bei
mcdonald's nicht weil das ist ja jetzt
nicht so was passiert jetzt hier mit
meiner kamera stehen und kurzen kath
obwohl jetzt geht's wieder also du
darfst kein trinken oder ja gut ist halt
so also wenn es vom chef so vorgegeben
ist oder vom von der ganz obersten etage
dann kann man halt nichts machen
eine frage die ich einfach mal mit
reingenommen habe weil ich so dachte
okay ganz interessant wenn jemand zu
wenig geld mit hat hast du doch schon
mal ein bisschen weniger verlangt
wahrscheinlich geht das nicht mehr
kannst du nicht machen oder kann ich da
nicht rausgeben
also wenn dann jemand sagt ich habe noch
80 cent für den bürger dann sagst ja gut
dann gehört da ist die tür
ja ist ja auch logisch also ich meine
weil du musst das ja am ende aus das
würde wenn die kassenabrechnung dann
gemacht wird bis zu dann normal oder
kassenabrechnung dem sinne also so wie
man es kennt das machen die chefs dann
sag ich mal die abteilungs die
schichtführer die sagen dann wenn
irgendwas mit der kasse nicht stimmt
aber
also wir machen das sowieso schon gar
nicht aber wieder vom trotzdem halten
wert rausgeben weil einfach ja das ist
in so einem unternehmen durch auch
selbstverständlich weil weg
jetzt laden sagen wo keine ahnung wie
viele umsätze gemacht werden und wenn
dann jeder so unter dem wert an
irgendwas kriegen würde weil er sagt er
zu wenig geld mit natürlich also das ist
einfach nur wirtschaftlich nicht tragbar
sagen wir mal so eine frage die ich
glaube das war die meistgestellte frage
ist ja auch logisch weil darin dreht
sich ja vieles in unserer gesellschaft
ich weiß nicht ob du das sagen kannst
wie viel verdienst du bzw wie viel hat
man dort pro stunde ungefähr verdient
mindestlohn oder ein bisschen mehr
ach so ich habe die schule gemacht habe
habe ich 150 euro von der arbeitsweise
ändert sich jetzt nichts machen
und wenn man dann halt vollzeit gibt es
ja auch noch es gibt ja vollzeit die
verdienen dann weißt du was die pro
stunde vor dem mindestlohn
ok also wahrscheinlich liegt schon nahe
dass es mindestlohn ist ok aber was mir
auffällt es gibt ja schon immer leute
also ihr habt ja es gibt ja leute die
haben zum beispiel diese ganz normalen
standard sachen an und es gibt leute die
haben dann irgendwie so einen anzug an
oder so leicht enthemmt weißt du so ein
blaues fällt mir manchmal auch das sind
dann die leiche oder die schichtführer
die haben dann meistens dieses
mcdonald's entlassen
die sehen dann ein bisschen anders aus
die haben dann auch so andere schuhe
sogar also ja meistens alle so alle
schwarze extra geschichte der schule
weil wenn es fertig ist oder so und man
nicht ausnutzen
und die verdienen aber auch mehr schon
das weißt du aber nicht nee aber ich
gehe davon aus weil das habe ich mich
immer gefragt inwiefern die sich von den
anderen dort absetzen
das war jetzt gerade auf fünf fragen wir
sind schon bei neun minuten also die
zeit verfliegt immer schnell wenn man so
ein video auf dann hoffe ich mal auch
für dich als nächstes kommen wir zu der
zeit meist gestellten frage ich paare
die jetzt einfach mal am anfang raus
weil wahrscheinlich sind das so auch die
fragen die euch alle interessieren und
zwar wenn du dort arbeitet darfst du dir
immer belohnt was umsonst nehmen oder
darfst du dir alles nehmen was du willst
oder nicht
also wir verdienen halt pro stunde mal
so ein bestimmtes essensgeld und dann
dürfen wir uns den wert den wir dann
einen stunden gearbeitet haben zum
beispiel also wenn du jetzt mal
angenommen pro stunde dann eines lohn
von einem euro bekommt und 19
mitarbeiter das dürftest du für neun
euro essen also merkt euch wenn ihr bei
mcdonald's seit über den schränken
stehen angebrochene getränke ach so
genau wenn du dann aber selber jetzt
sagt er ich hab grad mega hunger ich tue
ich weiß jetzt drei euro in die runde
und würde ihn gern drei duisburger essen
dann darf das auch nur in der pause
wahrscheinlich ist ja ist ja logisch
auch einfach irgendwas bezahlen nachdem
es gerade nach dem jetzt fast unsere
pizza hier verbrannt ist habe ich mich
wieder hingesetzt und wir kommen zur
nächsten frage haben auch sehr viele
gestellt wäre ich gar nicht drauf
gekommen gibt es eine festgelegte
wartezeit bei der der kunde bei zu
langem warten die bestellung kostenlos
bekommt nicht dass ich wüsste also ich
weiß dass ab einer bestimmten zeit jeder
weiß
so nett war und gesagt tut uns echt leid
fürs warten dann haben wir meistens noch
ein eis dazu gelegt oder so haben
gefragt ob die vielleicht noch irgendwas
wollen
also wenn ich zwei stunden auch meine
bestellung gewalt habe hast du dann
gesagt you here christoph also ich habe
in unserem betrieb jetzt mitbekommen
also also als die gäste hatten
wahrscheinlich auch mal was war so das
schlimmste erlebnis was sie mit einem
gast hat ist oder kann sich daran noch
erinnern
das ist schwierig also es gibt oft
besoffene leute die eben teils sehr
aggressiv reagieren auf andere
betrunkene gäste zb und dann eskaliert
das war ich glaube einer zum beispiel
hat sich irgendwie mal von mcdonald's
weitergegeben oder so mag dann die ganze
zeit auf dem boden also kann man nicht
raus und dann muss das geklärt werden
also ich weiß nicht so nah gut also aber
klar das hat man wenn man irgendwo ein
restaurant führt was nach 10 oder nach
nur auf hat wo leute dann auch alkohol
trinken oder mehr leute alkohol trinken
ich glaube da bleibt das nicht aus wie
bist du dazu gekommen dass du gesagt
hast
ich hätte es mal bei mcdonald's zu
arbeiten weil du hast ja hast mir eben
erzählt dein abitur auch gemacht
nebenbei also mein fachabi ich habe mich
dazu entschieden weil also freunde von
mir haben dann schon gearbeitet man kann
halt als schüler als student muss ich
sagen echt gut geld verdienen also es
geht auch recht schnell also ich würde
es auch ehrlich gesagt den leuten
empfehlen also wenn die jetzt so
nebenjob suchen oder so schülerjobs also
wirklich den echten vielen snacks zu
gehen ich hatte das glück dass ich echt
nette leute hatte also wir haben uns im
team mega gut verstanden hat auch spaß
gemacht also gleich war nicht korrekt
drauf und wenn ich immer so witze reißen
zwischendurch weiß ich seit schüler job
finde ich eignet sich das echt gut aber
ich weiß nicht ob ich das dann halt so
hauptberuflich machen würde
sage ich mal weiß dann doch schon
manchmal echt stressig ist das haben
auch viele gefragt ob manchmal halt halt
stressig ist oder wenn du dann halt an
der kasse arbeitet oder am 3
und dann vielleicht auch noch mal
wechseln muss oder so und dann viele
leute kommen und dann auch noch oben ob
sie wieder gesagt hast ist
wahrscheinlich schon stressig war nicht
so stressig kann es auf jeden fall seien
vor allem wie man dann im drive alles
voll hat und in der lawi alles voll hat
und du musst also meistens arbeiten bei
magna ist jetzt nicht so viele leute wie
alle davon aus- gehen also es werden
eigentlich mehr arbeitskräfte benötigt
sag ich jetzt mal und wenn dann so die
leute mit dem tempo nicht hinterher
kommen weil wir hatten mal einen fall
glaube ich da standen bis zur einfahrt
bis zum parkplatz von mcdonalds aller
autos am treff und frage mich wer sich
dann noch extra hinten dran stellt mit
dem auto nur um auf 1 1 zu warten so gut
und vielleicht um das video jetzt
abzuschließen weil wir hatten gerade die
sensationelle idee dass wir doch einen
zweiten partner machen wo wir dann im
auto die anderen fragen klären und mal
bei mcdonald's vorbeifahren du kannst ja
doch noch mal gucken wie diese ob sie
das das kommt dann halt die tage online
vielleicht schon morgen je nachdem
es kommt natürlich auch wir haben ja
eben schon mal darüber gesprochen so was
für jene angeht weil das wollen
natürlich auch wenn es viele wissen wie
ist die qualität und wie werden die
bürger dort zubereitet ist das
hygienisch gesehen gut oder hast du da
auch schlechte erfahrungen mit gemacht
kann es ja einfach mal deine erfahrung
sagen also ich habe jetzt nichts gesehen
was mich erschrecken sagen ich mache
also ich weiß natürlich nicht wie das in
anderen filialen ist ich kann das jetzt
weil man muss ja dazu auch sagen dass
viele privat geführt werden und ist ja
eigentlich wie dann auch einen allein
schönes restaurant
manche führen dass hygienisch gesehen
besser manche schlechter dass es wird ja
nicht alles vom selben geführt deswegen
wenn da einer darauf achtet ist es denke
ich mal
hygienisch gut oder nicht
in der lobby scart ausgang mal bitte
nochmal durch die lobby oder so also es
wird schon wird schon drauf geachtet zb
das sehen auch oft die kunden wenn zum
beispiel jemand einer friteuse steht und
eben einmal die chance für runter fällt
kann es ja nicht
ja das wäre ja das würde ja gar nicht
gehen wir auch für das wasser in der
friteuse gewechselt da dieses öl dass
das wurde auch oft gefragt ist mir
gerade eingefallen
alles klar dann würde ich sagen haben
wir schon einen langen ersten part
gedreht das geht jetzt bestimmt schon an
die 20 minuten deswegen erstmal danke
dass du mitgemacht hast und wir
schwingen uns jetzt gleich ins auto und
dann bin ich mal gespannt wie der zweite
part wird bestimmt noch lustiger
deswegen schaut euch das sehr gerne die
tage an lassen doch nach oben da und was
ich an dieser stelle auch noch sagen
möchte
da habe ich die kamera auf diese idee
gebracht hat habe ich so gedacht
vielleicht kann es auch mal ein
interview führen mit im lieferando
fahrer oder mit einem burger king
mitarbeiter oder einem schwindler ist
mir auch noch einen gefallen
das heißt dass richtet sich jetzt an
euch wenn ihr in diesem berufsfeld tätig
seit und bock habt dass man mit mir zu
machen ich stelle keine schlimmen fragen
oder so nur das was sie selber wollt
dann schreibt mir gerne über instagram
alex wie und bei cover könnte auch bei
insidern vorbeischauen möchte dann
schreibe ich mal in die video
beschreibung wirklich vielen dank für
die lange zugfahrt und wir drehen jetzt
noch weiter das war's schöne grüße
daumen nach oben und ciao